hello everybody happy Friday
splatoon day we have splatoon - here we
got splatoon Joy's probe controllers LG
joy cons we got amiibos we're gonna open
up later Joey let's just get right into
this game I am so excited yes it's uh
it's been a while
well actually no for you've been a while
for me for me I've been playing a little
bit but yeah welcome guys to our suite
oh wait first off go back that's me
right there oh there you are your
friends around this area which is cool I
am also gonna be playing as well before
we get to a match Joey show me them hot
miiverse post alright let's let's go
look at some of these people it's day
one day one posts there's a lot of text
posts right here this is my favorite so
far
shout out to Steve Kim yeah Steve Kim
released neck to let Ruby crystal have a
center sure not sure I don't know who
that is
let's say animate sucks over there oh is
it this guy yeah I think I also saw a
different enemy sucks
I think that it might be the same person
she marina two guns is that Mario dad
that looks like Mario mails okay anyway
I'm gonna try and join you here
by the way I am gonna be why I'm playing
I'll also be we'll both be looking at
the chat
I feel free answer any questions you
guys have about the game especially Joey
because he's actually played a lot he's
at level 13 oh yeah yeah he's been
playing a ton I'm just got in I'm a
little yeah I'm gonna have any different
no gear anything no hopefully we'll get
you to level four before the end of the
stream pretty yes yeah it's cool when
you get in here you can just hit join
friends I know it let me just let me get
into again into a lobby and then it'll
say joinable and you can just join your
friend there and then hopefully I get
into a match for them if not though they
actually that's really cool now looks
like I didn't okay so basically on my
screen it says standing by it actually
tells me how long Joey's matches which
is pretty nice let's look at some
comments here Oh
Callie's asking for questions she says
hey Joey what's your favorite stage and
what's your favorite weapon favorite
stage so far I really like this one
actually the starfish main stage bottom
left is great yeah that's actually
pretty good
all we're covering is the booyah and
this way you'll be able to see it anyway
as per favore weapon you're seeing it
right here the arrow spray mg which is
their they're like
let's go over this here to this guy we
got Jake here not our Jake I don't think
oh no maybe
okay Kelly since that's also her
favorite weapon yeah I mean until we get
until we see like some of the other new
ones like with different loadouts here
because in the original game the arrow
spray hat or then the air spray mg had
the the seeker which was like my
favorite sub weapon
here it's the the suction bomb which is
okay yeah I can't I bring it to a good
deal with it our Jake is level 13 yeah
different Jake where are you funny about
how I saw this with the Wii U - just the
way you like handles yeah knows much
there's a lot of just like oh I'm
playing against TJ and Billy Billy I'm
gonna get really mad at Billy because
it's not doing this job
Danijela because there's no in-game chat
not yet it will be the latter you think
oh in game yeah again probably not
knowing Nintendo I can't see that
actually happening that system they have
seen so an elegant I like straight up do
it better but where's my slats at I'm
just sawing friends this is one of the
maps in the
it looks so different in Oh like you're
in daytime the times just like kind of
going off to the side seeing the
environments here some barbed wire
around Apple Alexis's what's your
favorite sub weapon sub weapon um right
now I gotta think about that one another
person's asking pros and cons of this
game they're thinking about picking it
up pros and cons it's probably one of
the most unique shooters you'll ever
play it has like really really like just
like cool cool ways of moving around the
game that you won't really see in other
game right cons like as we mentioned
before there is no there's not like an
elegant voice chat option really like
Nintendo is kind of very like once a
gingy with like kind of getting with the
times like with PSN and xbox I think we
won that despite not doing a whole lot
in that first match Oh 1% Wow I looked a
lot close a lot less close grand minor
yes by 22 is not a baby's game yeah
they're so early who was saying it was a
baby's game yeah not for babies like as
far as the okay yeah you can argue that
the there are the main characters our
kids it's a very colorful but I wouldn't
say this for babies like good kids group
says just yellow ink randomly I'd say
another issue I had with this game is
when you're not partying up with friends
you're not able to coordinate with your
team weapons which can ya be pretty
important and you can't switch the mid
match which for no reason that I can
really think of as far as like balance
or anything I and you know I think it's
just because that's only that's only
relevant in turf war where it just kind
of meant to be a casual thing so that's
probably why it's casual but you want to
win true you win and you got three
people with the the splat charger we're
not gonna win each yeah three charges is
not going to
not gonna get rollers on our team all
right so we've got the surgeon shipyard
I'm playing now Amelia says how long
have you played up to this point um I
haven't checked the actual hours yet but
um level 13
maybe like what's 10:15 let's say yeah
probably you'll be able to check not
that's not like that would be including
the the single-player mode as well which
is pretty extensive right I was checking
I put a good five hours into that yeah
the whole thing
this little bit make the town purple I
like that I've never colored here okay
said I'm gonna come around on their side
Oh No
run away oh [ __ ]
I got flanked I'm gonna ink some of the
the base is actually put in 35 hours 35
hours it's pretty good it's a lot a lot
of time in the same poor Mario feeling
neglected well he doesn't have this game
yeah
oh no oh we got we got a couple people
on our base yeah David Campbell's asking
if we played any other switch games yes
quite a bit I like to switch a live game
Jake were just Todd this is like a
sentiment I tell you please put all the
video games on the switch I'm definitely
oh eh
I do not like this it's okay I kind of
like the the new super it has the was it
what's it called again this or it makes
your entire team invincible for like a
couple seconds like it's nice because it
doesn't matter where they are on in the
stage your blues a lot more blue than
mine well it's kind of purple yeah no
mines purple well you might just be in
the monitor
[Music]
we are not doing so well and I just
killed Ocala mention started Valley on
Swift yes why can't I keep forgetting
about that you know yeah I played a lot
crap oh I got hit by all the missiles
yeah I think I got hit by someone else's
mrs. Jake it's all your fault
Oh Peyton Gervase is saying what's your
favorite switch game once now that this
is out I can say slaw tune - yeah I
would say that I mean Zelda it no I
don't want to get into that right now
I'm not gonna get into that right now as
as of this moment it's splatoon - sure
because I'm playing it right now that's
fair yeah this will probably beat it but
I've been told now it's been Mario Kart
8 is but the one I'd probably like
invested the most into playing a lot of
that level - yeah that you get the first
couple levels really easily in this oh
you already level - yeah it slows down a
lot I remember it was a 2800 experience
I have 26,000 to go yeah slows down a
lot
Kelly say she's trying to join us I
don't know that that that office
Internet right all right well she's
definitely out in this match maybe she
could get into the next one this is no
party option some kind of there are so
the splatfest there is a legit party ah
yeah this way it doesn't seem like
there's a party option but you can say
hey I want to join my friend you can
join their game we can join the early
game and and if you don't get in time
it'll just like what it actually like
lets you know how long the match is
gonna last which is pretty nice yeah but
the thing is that you can't you can't
like say oh I want to stay in your party
the entire time it kind of just
randomizes it although now that um once
you're playing with a friend it seems
like it'll try and keep you guys in the
same match does it yes cuz we're on the
same match right now I'd have to redo
anything so I think wants to join a
friend in our in a match your you seem
good to go yeah that guy Oh
Jake and I have not been the good terms
with each other it seems like it's
getting trades the entire time all right
better be safe up there
I cannot activate my invincibility yeah
yeah I know Jake yeah Andy Taylor league
battle is party based but you need in
order to play a lead battle you need to
get your ranks your rank score all the
way up to the B minus a tweaks okay
local multiplayer at this time yes or
well so they're easy they have from the
get-go like private matches which they
eventually added in one as far as like
local like split-screen I thought there
was but I'm not 100% no there's they
still haven't done that I don't I don't
know if they ever will
I think the reason they wouldn't is
because I'm a big thing that this game
is is a very solidly locked second
Oh with that guy Joe ban that was a bad
bad spawn yeah I'm gonna jump I think it
should be all crap Jake let's do pretend
I'm yelling it are Jake I'm gonna go off
no don't follow me oh dude I think they
know they didn't they didn't no way no
cuz I came I went around to the back oh
you did come around yeah it's gonna be
close 11.1% awesome whoo fantastic I'll
get us all getting I'm getting gear I'm
unlocking abilities would you go there's
a little that point one percent though
oh man ever anytime that happens it's
like your heart almost almost dies
Dave Campbell says this for a family or
just kids like everyone everyone
everyone can be a squid kid every soul
on the same team now looks like we are
yeah I guess a trick is it tries to do
that as yeah that's cool
almost are just getting extremely lucky
here what if you like more or once more
people start times play say more than
four back Oh threw a bomb at a guy is
everyone I'm just in the middle yeah I
haven't seen anyone yet are you guys
just like hanging out in the back or
something no I'm in the middle there we
go and so this this stage has these
little rotating platforms on the side
just be careful cuz I've jumped onto one
thinking that it was you know in the
same spot and then I just bawled my
death
on kitty
well.all point sensor take those things
or no those were the well if someone has
the you know what they're called like
the the ink bombs yeah but they just
like slow you down right there
right
[Music]
whoa now there
it's two guys on on our left side here
looks like they went down one died make
my way around that ravine says his
father's can't wait to play it
absolutely dude yeah I'm joke I the
whole weekend do you say stoked or I
heard choked and scouts choke the word
revenge thank you oh man this is a has
been a very good match for me
retreat a little bit we're coming on the
mouth Oh
we got this whoo we didn't oh he thinks
fly me at the end you do this flash down
that looks cool yeah it looks like the
the ink strike and the last game Brett
ESA's darude Inc storm I agree deuces
wins rocky Lee got a switch oh yeah
that's coming yes later this year keep
it rolling so once once you get the
level for that we'll head out you can
buy some stuff and uh while I'm doing
that you should check out these we got
these amiibo
oh yeah it's like we got some people on
the team here mg some K and M G Gus DK
three clan probably plan hoodude wolf
yeah we are gonna change our gear once
jean-luc gets to level four and which
we'll be able to buy some new stuff oh
yeah you can change the music oh yeah
you can like warp it a little bit with
the d-pad and all the buttons do you
play with tilt on oh uh yes with a
controller I don't like using it with
handheld yeah it's it's really hard to
see but like if you haven't if you have
the game and are like a little bit weary
on using the motion controls I would say
give it a chance because I think they're
the way to go yeah Tony was just asking
if we're using motion controls yep I
don't I think I don't like the feel of
the non motion tickles I know it's like
well it's it's it's weirder because I
guess because it's a third person so
first-person shooter
I don't know but yeah motion controls
are definitely a way to go at least for
me so this is John Lee Picard yep that's
me have you ever not gotten that on the
stream I don't know I don't get that
ever in youtube comments well also it's
here already
of course
all right
Brett was saying I have to motion
another try they were trying to testify
it's gonna get the hang of it yeah give
it a fair shake
oh boy our legal lived cally was saying
how she thinks that motion controls are
the way to go
Oh No
whoa
you see that guy yeah we need to need to
ink our base a little bit I'll get I'll
do that all right
no I just think this because this game
is so it's pretty quick I think like
motional just really helps out like just
aiming right is half the time you're
gonna be concentrating on you know
running away trying to be like turning
into a squid everyone just ganging up on
that guy it feels just very cumbersome
to have to use the d-pad or the analog
stick to change at all I got like three
splats from that ah that guys backing up
okay we are looking pretty good right
now son says he's on Sonic
Oh 404 I don't know something like there
was no Sonic that came out in 2004 well
I'm sure there was a sonic rush for the
DS there's Sonic 4 which is not Oh for
now I don't I don't like Sonic 4 okay we
got some trouble over here there is
Sonic maybe coming out which would be
pretty great I'm very excited about that
that game is gonna be pretty good you
better know often do I get deep
friendship what do you mean like like
people are being like oh I'm not really
French I do get I'll get sometimes and
it's so awkward like a delivery guy will
come by no be like John Luke and you'll
be like say something in French to me
and I like know what I'm surprised that
you get delivery guys that actually can
speak French or will say like any other
word besides like people here in
yeah Quinn Stewart the s for motion
controls the most part I'll actually use
the the analog stick to turn like left
and right oh yeah and just basically use
the motion controls to kind of fine tune
my aiming like while I'm inking the turf
instead of having to go use use the
stick it's like move left and right I'll
just kind of wiggle it around it's like
it's not my main I don't want to say
it's not my main way of aiming but it's
like more yeah like I said more for fine
fine tuning
David Campbell says is this as good as
the Wii games I assume you're referring
to the Wii U game splatoon one I'd say
so far based on my initial impression I
mean it's it's not any worse definitely
no I don't see how it could be goop says
hashtag let Kelly in if we could we got
those uh those guys again yeah
oops is that person he says that Dave
Jewett hates motion controls he doesn't
know what to believe believe believe us
believe Kali Dave doesn't know what he's
talking about
yeah coin you can go full motion
controls if you use like the the Y
button like a lot it's clearly meant to
be worked in combination yeah I mean if
it works for you then by all means go
ahead and do that man taking a while to
find this person
no one more Coop's is Dave's beard is
very convincing I'm sure he has a
wonderful beard what are the those
little we got a person next to your
coins your money what what is that oh
those are the super was that super sea
snails that was the currency in order to
in the first game like randomizer gear
like we roll it and also if you noticed
there's a there's a little icon next to
the the weapon down I have basically it
goes from dry to fresh and then you know
keeps on going up and that's like a
little bonus for you that's a every I
think once it reaches ten you'll get a
little freshness bones and a like a
3,000 experience like extra and in
addition to whatever match you won
oh yeah I'll just take a mint quick did
not realize that
den worth man is asking if the game
matches people with others of the same
rank right now mostly it might just be a
little skewed since I'm in a group with
jean-luc and I'm marking at level 13 and
and also everyone else no one else would
be a little yeah right unless you were
able to like get it early or something
right right stay off Oh
so my invincibility thing doesn't work
against other supers wait what really I
used it and I still got oh it's like too
strong maybe yeah
like someone used their super it can it
can handle like a couple hits from like
and like it's just a regular blaster or
like a shooter or something like nothing
nothing too heavy I guess
man yeah careful that guy down there or
wherever he went I'm gonna ink some of
our turf here yeah we gotta get this
back or leftism ruins our left yeah all
right I'm on it I think I'm getting in a
little bit all right
we're okay on this side no
all right taking them Oh God
roller
I just realized we are on separate teams
we are yeah oh I was like wait a second
ours is what are you talking about the
left style McQueen's a second this is
fine oh this is gonna be close actually
oh yeah I just realized that because I
tried I tried jumping to you I was like
bloody kill you probably noticed
oh dang I thought I did pretty well I
see yeah I did the best on my team yeah
always the best yeah we just kind of
kind of assumed that we were yeah thank
God was an ink saver for the bombs you
right there you can look it up but you
got a few more matches or the level 4
get the level 4 apparently they noticed
right away and yeah squit stone wrong
pants max Fricks
one more so you can see that low icon
right there underneath my level right
now it's at 11.5 and I think every 10
points you'll get that bonus so it's
like it's kind of like in the just
encouraging you to stick with that
weapon try to get better at it right
because every time you win you'll level
that up
and we're playing real people yes there
we are I don't think there is any box in
this game no I'm all game again room all
right
good screen sheet see where you are yeah
I am on your side
back to baby I love that I love that
they put the fever stuff in the that was
bad that you now like I'm an axe
you don't come through joy and all these
please be safe No
Oh squits ttan that's good man they got
themselves a switch adjust for splatoon
whoa so I know why you're playing a girl
neat yeah cuz they have cool hair that's
why I pick the girl whoa all right you
guys are a little bit too much on our
sides push it back a little bit up there
you
oh my god oh it's going over here trust
me my team is doing like to try to get
in on you guys
Oh God
Oh me blaster the blaster got me right
away
oh I have that turnout I'm not really
sure
oh yeah I thought I was I don't my rest
of my team Wednesday when I was trying
to make it was pretty it was it was a
you guys had a very good early lead
you boasted about longevity this game
you think would be playing for months so
they're gonna provide free content a new
map here all that stuff
they said for a year and they're gonna
have to you yeah for at least year I
mean and things with the splatfest are
great because if you're like I'm playing
a bit and you're like others despite
fast I'll pop in and play some per day
it's a good way to kind of like get you
excited yeah are you look at it
I was trying read that one comment it
wasn't worth reading
all right probably on the same team
again
we got that nickelodeon orange oh yeah I
love that just what's the other one it's
purple right what or the other key
they've all done any like splatoon
marketing with Nickelodeon that seems
like the autumn I could have sworn they
did at some point like the only thing I
can remember is like the supply fest
where it was uh spongebob versus with
spongebob versus Patrick that's pretty
good was it hit right there there was a
spongebob there I'm not sure if I I
caught that one but yeah uh Murray oh I
think does not make you invincible in
this bowl which one my super or the ink
armor yeah yeah just it can just absorb
like maybe a couple of hits
there you go
yeah I'm going up here - oh no I fell
off stay away
dead worth mean says sniper actually any
good yeah it takes takes a little bit of
time to get used to and you're it's not
gonna be great on every single map like
there are some words where it's
definitely better than others but it's
like a very good like oh my god it's a
very good option if you can like if you
can get good at it I would also say you
don't really want more than like one
person on - yeah yeah
this guy is just on your tail oh she
didn't felt at home how we doing oh he's
got a roller okay I'm jumping to you so
there's all three of them oh I just got
hit
I'm alive I'm alive I'm sure how I
survived that
because I got here okay I think we
should be okay if you clean that up
clean that stuff up
how do we do how do we do a lot of
people are talking about the arrow spray
ooh I think we got it please not 1%
again okay
8% yeah the arrow spray is very good
it's probably I think I used it the most
in splatoon one cuz a has a good rate of
fire to has a very very like widespread
see your it works works wonders for both
inking and attacking so attuned to Evo
2018 not a tivo now maybe in its own
thing what that uh that um announcement
trailer for this phobia were they
basically in arena arena like a dota 2
level international arena one more match
and I should hopefully get really good
Fabian Martina says he's or he or she is
gonna get this game today but gotta wait
till my game stop opens surprise are
open already it's what it's 11 o'clock
unless they're somewhere else in the
world other than the United States
candle so should I buy her no definitely
buy if you have a switch absolutely
definitely look when the the jets
culture kind of forgot about that weapon
and I never really used him much it has
like a I know it has a really long range
looks like real same team pink mr. OWL
Mansoor wants to know what's the
objective of the game so the whole point
is they're trying to enter for you want
to ink up and control the most turf
the beginning you want to try and get
like as much ink as possible then at
that point it's know what the slosh are
back here wrestling ouch or certain
areas from the enemy and that's kind of
like the main game mode for yeah yeah
picture for there are other ones in
which have like some different
objectives which we can actually go to
thank her for is such a strong mode
though yeah oh my oh point Oh Hitler mid
they kind of just ignored this whole
section over here on our left that's
fine with me just come over here okay
oh wow they kind of just keep that dang
it dang it dang it dang it
you know that's stupid slosher not happy
with that they reckon one guys just said
we don't really have a counter to that
is really hard I know you just gotta
pick one and hope that you have a good
team yeah hope hope for it we're doing
all right and filling some pink over
here oh no sauna coming nope
all right Murray is the only one alive
I'm gonna head towards the middle yeah
be a team wipe it's really easy to turn
things around
yeah when things up so nice Mario
obviously you don't know my Odyssey is
out in October
how'd we do whoo yes we got it so it
says what about arms or splicing arms or
I imagine they're asking like verses I
mean they're completely different games
I'll say that much all right well back
out this little loop get some gear and
you should so we have a bunch of the
amiibos here is it a me bow or amiibos
as plural I me by I think it's a me bow
I think Reggie has always referred to as
just amiibo like dozens of them eat well
so I guess we could open up the first
one which is the inkling girl
so yeah in the square you can go up to
this little section right here obviously
if you can actually just put it on if
that'll be easier no they have that
anyone can just grab it off the shelf
tap it on there and then now I have like
a little of like a magnetic strip at the
bottom that prevents you from doing that
I'm just gonna rip this open yeah so
cool oh okay
we got her right here you can see her so
let's see what she she gives us that's a
cool amiibo register it real quick to me
I'm just neighbor number one
cool oh hey number one super fresh vibe
I would like to be friends yeah so every
amiibo even the old ones they'll let you
save a loadout you know with your
weapons in gear
oh cool do it for me yeah just do it
right now might as well we'll see if she
gives me well exactly swap gear you can
be like put on this amiibo if this one
has this gear yeah
amiibo data is damaged we don't like to
restore it oh not sure what happened
there so are you buying all the weapons
I have to go through all this uh he's
just like explaining oh you can you can
actually oh yeah well you could do them
the first one - oh she got something for
me okay so she gives me the hair clip
just like in the first one except this
one has a little too on it just pretty
nice so alright so we got that one let's
open up the all the squid one actually
right here this one has some pretty
pretty sweet stuff I'll show you if it's
if it's the same one that they showed
off or if I'm remembering correctly the
one that they showed off earlier it has
a like a darkened ninja style gear the
clip for is it or boobs asking what the
clip is for the clip is a a head gear
slot those register this we're gonna buy
these splat Dooley's name one number
three you mean I really like about this
this one it's really tall
yeah like this looks this is all this is
no it's taller than the the calimary
amiibos and those were like you know
I'll hold it in place those were
actually really big compared to the
other ones
okay hello a little squid okay cool so
I'm able to buy all of the starter
weapons nice gun ain't got any money
left for gear I got 666 you buy some
shades a devil's number i buy shoot all
right so let's register doom let's bring
him back see what he gives me do it most
humble thinks he's gonna give me a gift
oh he gave me the power mask look at
this thing oh man I wanna take a picture
with them actually oh this is awesome
yeah when you tap your amiibos you can
also take photos with them that's like
different poses yeah you can you can
have them do different poses like just
standing there or you can have them
cross his tentacles oh that's cool
this one's just kind of a flopping
around on the ground this one's a little
bit faster okay this one just do that
okay
Quentin I'm not all that great with the
roller I never really practiced too much
with that kind of just one with the the
shooters and the Chargers mostly but
broglie's are always fun I'll say that
if you want to check out one of the ooh
the Kraken
splat roller which has the the new
special the holes are called you have
that new special where it's like you're
just stuck inside a bubble oh yeah
that's like the replacement for the
Kraken well this jacket looks nice take
a look some the gear and then we'll jump
right back into a match yeah whenever
gentle Mook is ready I'm ready whenever
I'm did you want to check the boy as
well how'd you get that samurai gear
that was from the old boy in clean from
the first splatoon I think I remember
that being up there well just I'm just
gonna open up all all the cardboard and
plastic just gonna be on the desk in
front of us for the next hour so come on
out
yes is it there's a little metal thing
that prevents you from doing that I
guess I just always thought like there's
so many people who like buy these and
never open them and I'm like how do you
use them you buy two of them that's
crazy
amoebas are meant for use yeah the
Kraken will be missed
unfortunately I really like that special
all right see whether the boy inkling
gives us
hmm yo what up wanna be friends okay
okay bring you back oh man look at that
merger you do all those cool stuff like
get rid of your secondary abilities put
new ones on ya role and so for merch all
his own the currency that you use is
actually earned from salmon run hmm
apparently also so you can order gear
from him
you can also apparently order it with
the app yeah I was doing that the other
day I'm like oh this is amazing
that's cool okay restore does it keep
doing that it's I think it's because
I've been moving it weird they want to
restore dead okay one more time
all right there you asked for bonus I
don't have any bonuses all right let's
see what he gives oh the squinty mask
okay I think I need to put some of these
on so which one do you think so we got
the the squinch a mask the power mask
mark well like that or the clip where is
it
oh no they're not oh they're earrings oh
I didn't see that that's cool those are
cool I think you got to go with the
power mask I mean how you not okay this
is where these from gadgets desk no I
shot - Nick margarita who was that Best
Buy and ran out and grabbed a bunch okay
let's go with some I ordered some from
Walmart but unfortunately they won't be
arriving until next Friday even though
they told me they were supposed to
arrive - yeah delays okay I'm not sure
if anything really matches with this
power mask I'm just gonna go with the
black no electricity and I'll change my
weapon I'll try out see is there is
there any anyone the chat that wants to
see like a specific weapon that I have a
specific weapon typed I can always uh
try them out let's see
are you gonna try the immeubles now yeah
I'm gonna try my own I brought my own
amiibo so I can get my own stuff I'll
just do this while you guys are see I'm
actually starting like the splat lean a
lot more um just like the strategy with
this kind of hold like oh it capped her
name from when I named her and uh
greetings from Cali Cali
it's my amiibo okay I think for now I'm
gonna go with the heavy splatling so I
was trying to guess my age who don't
tell him tell me you're immortal
apparently this amiibo is locked to
Kali's oh you're gonna have to undo it
and everything yeah Kali we're gonna
have to fix this I can't get any of this
gear alright people want to see that
crazy machine gun which I I equipped so
we'll do that
Kali stole my amiibos from me we'll jump
back into a game absolutely yes
what are you doing it's a speed tactic
move faster that way no you don't look
at look at this look at this dice I need
to get the rest of the the gear the
power gear alright gonna jump it to
online all right yes and I'm joining Oh
seems like it's pretty hard to join your
friend immediately at the same time yeah
I have to wait until you're in this
lobby here and then I have to enjoy
there you got it
I was able to get in but like I was like
the last person yeah Tony says amoebas
are dangerous for him they are there's
nothing to stop me
buying them all now that I'm an adult
that's true like I remember when they
first announced I told myself and I'm
not gonna I'm gonna buy these yeah
don't collect toys right okay not yet
now I do apparently I mean also I have
here a another one that Joey picked up
for me you were trying to pick yeah all
right so you guys since so you guys
haven't seen it before this is the the
heavy splatling which is basically like
a huge minigun and you charge up and
then you just let go with pink and it's
it's one of the most I'd say it's like
one of the highest dps weapons in the
game just because of how fast it'll kill
people like once you have a direct hit
on them
Oh Oh get them home track that's the
thing once I got your you get planes
yeah that one especially with that
weapon yeah this is this is something
that you do not want to be in the middle
of the arena with wouldn't be like on
the side in the back like backing up
your whole team because this thing has a
lot of range and you can nail people
from pretty far away with it
I'll get that guy dang it
got a little from up there I didn't yeah
that thing has a lot of range like it's
it's kind of deceptive the splashdown
I'm gonna stay back
so the Stingray one of the cool specials
cool new ones and can go through walls
which is a little overpowered I kind of
actually missed the the killer whale
remember that one from the first one
where it was basically the same idea
it had like that sound wave that travel
right but it was a lot faster okay they
have in Carmel
who's Garrett there
I did nothing for that
well this guy is dead mm-hmm sorry
Isabel Oh is everything good nope I got
them very least
oh oh it was put up
damnit
so it says no Chu player offline mode
not that we're not that we can tell
there's no screen also no to Claire
online so if you want to play online
with a friend they'll have to have their
own switch yeah
this just came in today for me yeah do
you think they'll ever release those uh
the neon joy comes in America Oh bad
he'll know why they release it in the UK
and Japan but not here it was Japan and
then they released it oh now the UK okay
I feel like I feel like the UK is
they're like really pushing spot tune
there cuz I don't know I feel like it
wasn't as popular during the first in
the for the first game and now they're
like I've seen like so many pre-order
bonuses like these exclusive joy cons
and everything like I think if you
pre-ordered it in the UK you would get
like a shirt or a hat Wow yeah like um
over the the UK team I think will Potter
he was he like tweeted about that was
like oh yeah I had that are you
surprised to switch is so much fun
not really yeah I'm glad it took off
yeah that's that been the biggest thing
I was worried about the switch like I
want Nintendo to have a successful
console and I think after the Wii U
everyone was kind of like they weren't
exactly sure what to expect with it but
I'm really glad that
I do not do you not do not challenge the
splat leap see you guys over there
oh we actually a lot of our area when
you have not covered yeah I'm gonna get
to it or I take it all here who is it
Michael yeah Brett the the mini guns
nice it takes a little bit of time to
get used to just because you can't
really do that uh the whole thing about
inking and then diving back down to the
ink like right away you kind of have to
every every shot that you do it has to
rev up a little bit but I think it's
worth if you if you have patience which
typically I have hey Tony have
oh boy since there's no other control
really good I like him but it seems like
a lot of people are still pretty mixed
about motion controls I mean until they
actually try it you know right it's like
the whole thing like with like the whole
gimmick you know with with the we in the
wheels like people didn't really like it
a whole lot at first but like once
they've incorporated into like a
multiplayer shooter like this it just
shows like how good it can be
dang it Joey that range on the splatling
though the damage oh yeah
it's also got a sprinkler which is nice
yikes you guys breakfast
mmm mmm so satisfying hmm
very pouty about it Robbo Robin says
they're gonna go grab the game today the
first watt tune was amazing
that's correct I really really hope you
enjoyed the second one no I know I'm
having a blast with it give his mics and
a friendless like come on I think
there's a there's a friends list the
game does have that and we do have mics
or phones you can use the phone that I
don't know if you guys heard about the
the whole setup about having to use your
phone for a voice chat in the game which
is not the most elegant solution right
as we all know not only is not only do
you have to use your phone if you want
to use like the official voice app but
you have to also leave your phone on in
the app the entire time which will just
kind of drain your bad range but it's
like what's stopping people from just
using discord over over this yeah like
you you do get like the app does give
you cool things like you can shop online
you could do some online shopping you
can uh you can also see like stats from
the last 50 vowels which is probably
like that's that's my favorite feature
absolutely yeah we are
oh my my
damn of you was me
okay oh I'll get my nope have you seen a
Steve splatfest pores Bieber's post
unlike the the walls here I saw it was
like on the uh oh my god
yeah there's a lot of I love that I
think with this fly passed up on me
versus that bomb on him this I really
called me verse I know it's just like a
kebab oh yeah
you know Willis you're gonna call it and
that was really the coolest thing
wonderful things love believe you that I
wish
nope nope nope
yikes
we're done there my dad angel is on your
team angel daddy
I'll make this romantic bedroom
oh okay guys you might need to paint
some of our turf please no it's fine
there's no reason to your church totally
safe
oh man is not
what dad angel
and the one thing about turf war is that
like a lot of it comes down to the very
last like 30 seconds like a lot can
change yeah absolutely
yeah yeah I got up in there a little Jeb
becomes big when you win and the music
is so Japan group says we were talking
about how this game just has like the
spirit of a gaming like the early
there's something there's something
about like green cast game it's just
something about like just the way it
looks the way it sounds and it's like
the weirdness of the 90s kind of comes
through in this game absolutely
I haven't haven't seen in a very long
time not only Smash Brothers a totally
he says a totally balanced Super Smash
Brothers for the totally balanced yeah
not if this this this ladies stays in
the game all that kid we went forget his
name captain Zach who's a he's a a
professional smash player he plays
Bayonetta he's one of the top in the
world he's 15 years old and he'll go on
to like stage with the Bayonetta music
and dance to it he wears like um like a
hood and like a bandana over his face
and he has a fan like he's the coolest
kid in the world and I love him like he
believes he's a cool kid or he like
actually is I think he is like he has a
swagger too and not alike a cheesy way
because some people try to do that and
they don't they like don't own it no so
it's just kind of weird so hard okay we
got charger on the other team we're on
the same team by the way Oh sick
oh my god sky pushed me all the way
oh we got that angel again ozone our
team yep Oh yikes tanner
mmm charger
you hear about the first slap so4 for
America is that the male versus ketchup
one yep
like how can that even be like I'm
assuming they're there they're talking
about like toppings and like Mayo is not
I died popularly I think right because
people some people eat french fries or
Mayo but not in America yeah American
back oh my got the charger careful I
think mustard would have made more sense
yeah catchman must because they're like
two things that people like together you
have to
dang it
well some of the chests talking about
Dragonball fighters ooh yeah we're all
very excited about that one
I know more that more than smash you
think just because smashes a new game or
right involves a new game
jump ring provecho said that that's not
going on the switch I'm okay with I
don't know if I need a fighting game on
the switch
yeah no no hmm yeah as far as like being
able to play one like on the go I'm not
sure if it's like ideal and also
necessary that shoot is team homemade
Mayo homemade Mayo
nice got it
oh yeah homemade meal I've actually
tried that one said the fourth all right
it's kind of fennel wasn't as thick as
regular mail couldn't really spread it
on anything without it falling off the
bread tastes good though
see how much time do we have going for
about an hour 15 all right do you want
to maybe after this maybe we'll go one
more and then we'll hop into a salmon
run good yeah I think that's one of the
things that we haven't really seen you I
even tried it all my first time maybe
Callie can get him this one lunch I mean
all of yesterday and the day before that
I was trying out there and couldn't get
it man that's cool figure this sticky
stuff on here not the ink like some
leftover residue from the machines that
made these Adam Fung is asking what role
does gear plays it just cosmetic
not only yeah so not only is it actually
really really like fashionable gear each
one has a main attribute which will give
you stuff like you know shorter respawn
time more damage like resistance to
enemy ink and then each one has up to
three slots that you can earn earn
abilities every time you level it up
you'll gain a random ability and that
will slot into there
and you can kind of like mix and match
to pay on your playstyle like if you won
like like if you if you just want to be
really really fast youqing the stack
like run and swim speed other ones the
exact damage or the people Wow
so yeah let's actually let's go to
[Music]
freeze Co so
my only worry is I might have to do the
tutorial alright alright well I can hop
in one why don't you hop and want to
show off
let's join the crew so if you guys
haven't seen salmon run yet it's
basically there a four player co-op
horde mode on which you're tasked with
collecting eggs from some of the bosses
that spawn around your little island
looking for a crew
David Campbell says gee uh do you like
Xbox
I like Xbox is there anyone working well
there we go just just me we got Jamie in
here and then sup we got Joey and also
Zoe and Dom number one team right here
sigh Burke man says how many squids must
die before the spittoon war is over the
splatoon wars are never over
they're constantly fighting I just do it
for fun
alright so we've got four players here
and each each each round or each wave
you're given a random weapon oh my god
I'm so I got a roller here so we have to
watch out for uh hordes of enemies as
well as the the bosses oh my
right where are they
don't lose the egg deposit the eggs and
then oh my god I'm not sure what
difficulty it is right now
you go
okay I didn't realize oh my god
the
so we've already lost oh wow I think it
might be because a couple of a couple of
team is we they immediately lift it up
or immediately made it high tide and so
I was just like ok I'm trying to jump
this jump I usually make okay grade was
95% it's too heavy kid
yeah Brett I'll know squids normally
they can only apparently can they can
only swim in their own ink not actual
water weird how that works I know some
I'm sure there's something in the lore
that explains why they don't know the
story and this one's weird
yeah like the story or just the story of
splatoon itself is kind of bizarre yeah
it's like post-apocalyptic humans are
like gone they only likes these squid
kids or squid people remain for whatever
reason
school personal is easy
like up Dooley's here
all right and see the boss Sam annoyed
alert is when a boss is starting to come
out and then right here and they'll drop
the the golden eggs which you collect
bring back
easy enough at first until they start
coming in droves and then people start
going down left and right yeah
especially like it seems like for online
you can't it didn't have a choice for
difficulty okay but no I'm not sure like
you can go from one zero to a hundred
hundred is pretty and or like I think
when we were playing even thirty was
pretty intense
apparently the water is polluted oh yes
green more training oh oh you gotta
learn all the bosses that's why yeah so
each each boss salmon will have like a
certain weak point that you'll you'll
have to have to learn how to fight like
this guy right here you guys like a
little he has a boy although I can't
talk right now
the giant piece of corn on the cob we're
up there oh and yours skewers what the
heck
oh here's the corn mister point is a
barbecue going on somewhere
please Co all right so each round as you
can see in the top left corner they have
a little quota that you need to meet or
for all the golden eggs oh my
say i GN UK is gonna do a 24-hour
marathon splatoon - good luck with that
that's that's a lot of splatoon to to
play in one day I remember I watched the
video for there there Mario Kart 8 one
just people slowly going crazy
that's nuts so we've got the low tide
right now to see like the land opens up
down here hey guys doing wait three yeah
are there three oh okay
you got throw a bomb into that dang it
please help me thank you
my keys popular so me and a pretty cool
remember I was having so much trouble
with the members but like once you learn
their weak spots comes pretty fun
because you can take on multiple ones at
once because it at higher difficulties
they're gonna start throwing like two or
three at you like we just killed one now
that here's another one already put the
same vacuum you have to defy divide your
time between getting the eggs back and
then killing the boss
we need seconds you got this
last one boom
alright clear the final wave nice last
of them so then we go back to the boat
and we can see our score and then we'll
get a point spaced off of how well we
did
individually damn Oh and depending on
how well you do you can get a bonus so
there's a little window on the side of
inkopolis square where you can like walk
up to them right and collect your bonus
so it gives you those ability chunks
were you out right now umbrella guy
although another one
someone the twitch chat is asking how
would you rate this for someone who will
mainly focus on single player as far as
single player content goes not too much
like the game is built around
multiplayer modes like this one salmon
run and then also the main multiplayer
so if you're just looking for single
player it's not gonna offer you a whole
lot I think the the story mode will run
roughly maybe five or six hours maybe
even less depending on how fast you can
get through it it is a fun singer player
mode from what I've seen them yeah I
know throw it in protein Oh
communication error has occurred Oh No
I know Evan on YouTube chat asking why
is there nothing about splatoon - right
now on YouTube or twitch when today is
release day that's a very good question
what do you mean I guess there's no like
front page like featured videos or live
streams we're doing something we're
doing some come watch us we're doing
things all right we got low tide here
take an Inc all this area
where are they
there you go I kind of like the idea of
the Sam run being like a job you have to
do or like that in Queens do in their
free time
oh it suggests uh have like parties
oh damn I'm doing so hot
no he's stealing our eggs yeah if you if
the eggs go untouched for a while you
can see that yeah one of the the same
noise will run up and like drag him back
into the water
now these we got our quota
I got the splash on jr. so for any be
joining us we are playing splatoon choo
here Joey is checking out the salmon run
mode right now we have the review which
went live on Tuesday yep done by the
wonderful callyblackie you should go
check that out I think we got a lot of
other like gameplay and stuff like that
yeah this game is cool though this games
a really fun song who loves the 1st
platoon and
excited forces in I can't I want to
spend all weekend play yeah where is
next one yeah
haven't appeared yet
who you was it get the eggs 30 seconds
hmm
let's go you can go get some more eggs
here all right cool yeah
Kaitlyn Aces High
hello thanks for joining us we are kind
of winding down on our stream but we'll
do a couple more salmon run matches
before we what we head off into the
sunset
check it both oh my god god no I didn't
throw it in but we got I gotta remember
to use my my special because you you're
granted two of them for every game
that's all you'll get
I always forget to use it
who are you at
go right next to the water so they can
drag it back in meskan strategies like
wait yeah don't just grab one abandon it
so revolution says they were never big
enough Latin lunch since it was kind of
boring
am I crazy is flat tuned to better
I certainly think splatting - seems more
like feature-rich like gain but if you
didn't love the feel of playing the
first Platoon this game is an a drastic
departure from that and so it probably
won't be too into spicy - like you know
people are saying how they should have
named it that I kind of disagree
actually Heath just because how would
you have you uh would you differentiate
vocally right I'm just playing playing
spike just what tune I get extra
oh you put my bonus review Carlos wants
to know our thoughts in the game so far
I've only been playing up for the stream
right now I'm in love with it Joey
you've been playing it for a while all
right I'm here I'm ready huh interesting
if you keep up with players whose job
titles aren't the same as there is he
may not be eligible for promotion I
think are you an apprentice yeah well so
am i oh okay
I will create a room okay we got a
creative room says it's full oh wait
what hey what happened oh no Joey no no
well you keep going can I leave do you
want to grab this one I never try yeah
here since you just learned all the the
the strategies for that I'll reach yet
see what oh yeah sure all right
Oh Joey are you playing Verdi yeah wait
what I mean inverted no no never mind I
mean typically I'll play inverted on
regular shooters it might just be like
different sensitivity yeah can't Lee
Jonathan is asking do you use the
charger thingy if you are charged up and
holding the ink yeah actually I need to
do that more often nowadays or you can
uh like hold the charge in while you're
what you swim in ink man they're all the
way over there grab it
don't see you David where is it oh it's
closer to the beach okay so kind of a7s
lads please explain the basics of the
game well as far as the the main
multiplayer mode turf war your your
grouped up into teams of four in which
you have different weapons that will be
able to ink the ground around you and
you want to have as much of your color
throughout the the stage as possible
this one however is a little bit
different it's more of like a you're
fighting against fords of enemies and
one try to collect those eggs and
deliver them to the basket over there
the regular eggs I think you get bonus
you get a larger bonus later on and yeah
that's like your personal performance so
like the weapons will change Oh high
tide careful
yeah the weapons will change every
every rail every way any of them make it
I'm led to have that whip oh mighty to
save up for the three
I tied to the pants I know is like
everything is closer together which
makes it a little bit easier to grab the
eggs but at the same time so much so
much stuff going on at once
these don't seem nearly as hard as
watching you guys play yeah I think it's
just your get stale guys scary though
yeah that last golden egg
zucchini get that bonus david says he'll
be back we probably won't by the time
you get back depending on if it's like
within the next ten minutes or so but
stick around you know we will have more
streams coming up in next week we
extreme everyday at 11:00
so make sure to catch those we're gonna
be here every Friday yep but you know
Monday's will have some streams and
Wednesday's is lobby Monday I know quite
a few people in the office have been
going crazy over over pub G I still
haven't gotten on the train yet but I
think this is just gonna delay that that
change even longer yeah Evan says
doesn't seem like the regular mode
spittoon is based on attacking people
just trying to paint them out
am i correct yes and no in a sense that
you can actually play an entire match in
turf war without ever like without ever
kill anyone and you can still like help
your team just as much as anyone else
so yeah so in that sense it's a very
it's a very different perspective on a
shooter game better right oh yeah you
got it all the eggs go keep my rap they
let me do all the work okay
are you gonna make it
call it effort yeah it's pretty good
27 golden eggs nice home sorry oh says
sub-games spit stop I think I got 411
eggs geez
okay so yeah that first bonus that you
get you can actually you're back out and
go to the guy in the menu or go to the
guy in the square okay
yes ago go back to the grisco area and
the far left and there there should be a
window Nexen where you can request a
bonus cool cube says he's also hang off
the pub G hypetrain
was at four thousand four four hundred
four thousand I see yeah so so plain
more you'll get a better you'll get
better bonuses every every every rink
you can do the same thing you could do
in on the first one where if you look at
them long enough they'll wave to you
really yeah I know that yeah if you went
in looked at calimary
they'll look at you in the wave how long
you know oh she spots us hey that's
pretty cool
alright let's let's do one more one more
co-op version okay I promise I think
there was an option to to get thank you
to search for other members if you only
have a couple of people so I think I
might have hit that first and just
grouped me up with everyone
okay like create a room okay okay yeah
this is recruit crew members I think I
might have hit that thank you that was
like oh yeah that opens up the room
that's just that brings in other people
okay now it's cool everything what is
there in terms of character
customization a whole lot there's just
there's tons and tons of gear that you
can buy from the stores like hats shirts
boots they have multiple hairstyles now
so we got Chanel and distortion in here
all right all right so if you're just
joining us we apologize this is actually
gonna be our last match of the day
mm-hmm but for everyone who's been
watching thanks from hey thanks a lot
for watching going through first couple
hours
look at mine yeah
this way
no gun no thought he wouldn't spot me
thank you
oh no egg for me just get the mobs here
I always think this splatter has more
range than an action I know you gotta
get the e leader I think that's my
that's probably my favorite weapon for
the first game that thing had such good
range like if you get people from so far
away without where they at
there we go
there we go
or yeah this way
Ted arts nothing's in my way
Oh are you dying I was trying to get
that angry I got you bring me more eggs
give me a cup Dooley's the egg basket
okay it's in the same spot this is a
spawn Oh
eight the bomb that's what you're
supposed to do except it's very
difficult and you have the the splat
bomb which rolls around a lot the vendor
feels like a suction bomb or something
is the next one
somewhere this way
sisterhood to the other ones
I got it I got it
I kinda like I was just a mad dash for
the egg like once they drop because they
know that people know that you can get
this yeah
all right wait don't forget my you're
special too right keep forgetting yeah
see someone's asking is the Stingray or
the only special for salmon run no
actually there there's splashdown
there's also the I think the one that
John Luke's using right now you can't
see it but it's the let's forget the
name of that one what yeah for years
like the jetpack one oh yeah man you
have like a bunch of different special
that you can use and you can only use
two every per game like once you can't
regenerate it once you use two you're
done
we got boss
all right all the eggs are spoken for
someone likes the sound of the Stingray
makes ya look like unnerving all those
so once to have the specialist decided
seems random yeah usually the the
charger like in the regular game the
charger has the stingray cuz it's long
range but in this case yeah it seems
like the
Oh randomized because the the weapons
that you start off with are also
randomized we'll get this one right here
yeah that's one fun oh don't pick it up
[Music]
Rickson in the YouTube chat asking do I
think that some do we think that some
weapons are clearly better than others
not necessarily because there's so many
different variations of right the
regular shooter or the rollers and each
one will have different sub weapons and
specials like you could like mix and
match with a whole bunch of different
stuff to customize basically how you
like plane exactly so there's no hard
yes this is better than this it's just
like mostly personal preference so I
think here thank you so much everyone
for watching the splatoon tooth dream
like I said we stream every Friday me
and Joey hmm at 11:00 and we also stream
just everyday a week day here at
GameSpot next week we're gonna have we
know that Jake and Mike are gonna be
doing of G yep I'm sure Rob and Pete are
gonna do something awesome and hilarious
on Thursday for the Triforce their zelda
stream right yeah so yeah make sure to
check those out if you want to see more
about splatoon - we got the review I got
tons of gameplay and maybe I'll see you
guys online thanks watching see ya